[Music]
on this thursday night gearing up for
debate
what's at stake in the english language
leaders debate tonight under pressure
alberta's plan to ease the strain on
hospitals as cobit 19 cases soar
surgeries
even if they're non-critical they are
important the patients left in limbo and
the need for more family doctors i
talked to one physician about what drew
him to a small town you get to know your
patients you get really meaningful
relationships plus taking flight this
was a rocket ship of the day how the
inventor of the telephone helped canada
fly into the era of flight right here in
badeck nova scotia
global national with donna friesen
we are in bedeck on cape breton island
nova scotia tonight nestled on the shore
of the breadure lake but deck is
described as the beginning and the end
of the world famous and stunning cabot
trail and a place where the migma have
lived for thousands of years
good evening and thanks for joining us
it's not just a stunning part of the
country the politics here in nova scotia
will play a role in the outcome of the
federal election of the 11 seats in nova
scotia 10 were won by the liberals in
2019. if liberal support is softening in
this election we could see the first
signs of that here in atlantic canada on
election night we're going to get to
important issues like health care and
housing in just a moment but we begin
with the english language leaders debate
tonight it's the only one of the
campaign and though it's high stakes for
all the leaders it's liberal leader
justin trudeau who has to convince
canadians he deserves a new mandate
abigail beeman is outside the debate
venue in gatineau quebec abigail what
will you be watching for
well donna i think the number one thing
to watch for is some more debate between
these two front runners who are so neck
and neck in the polls justin trudeau as
you mentioned and of course conservative
leader aaron o'toole i think a lot of
people will be looking for
more from those two last night during
the french debate block hip a quad
leader eve francois blanchett took up a
lot of the oxygen there it was a
different audience a different focus you
can expect that to be less relevant
tonight also we'll be looking to see how
ndp leader jug meet singh and green
party leader anime paul really try to
get their elbows up so to speak enemy
paul seemed almost uncomfortable in her
french last night tonight's english
audience much more important especially
in the steep uphill battle for her to
win a seat in toronto and for jug meat
singh looking look to see him try to
carve out some more space for himself
this evening
the last of the french language debates
as you mentioned last night what was the
tone of that one
there really didn't seem to be a
standout winner what you had were a
couple of standout moments perhaps this
was a two-hour debate just like
tonight's will be as well and those
moments didn't really come until much
later in the evening i'm going to share
one of them with you this was an
exchange between trudeau and blanchette
where trudeau is defending himself about
being a real quebecer and it's
noteworthy because it really depicts a
new tone that we've seen from trudeau
over the past couple of days i think the
best adjective to describe would be
fiery we've seen this from him on a
number of fronts have a listen
constantly you keep forgetting i'm a
quebecer i'm a proud quebecer i've
always been a quebecer i will always be
a quebec
and i will always have a say in what
happens in quebec you do not have a
monopoly over quebec
now in terms of timing and where we go
from here there's long been this idea
that canadians you know aren't paying
attention to this campaign until after
labor day that's that's what we've heard
well here we are after labor day this is
debate week tomorrow advance polls open
so whether or not that sentiment is true
what is true is that we're in the home
stretch here less than two weeks to go
which means that the runway is
shortening for leaders to show both
themselves to canadians and explain
their policies i'd also like to note
that our new exclusive polling from
ipsos for global news highlights a
staggering number that 68 percent of
respondents don't feel that a pandemic
is a time to hold an election that
includes about half of the undecided
voters who were pulled and the pressure
there really falls to liberal leader
justin trudeau who has to convince these
voters that not only is an election
justified and that they should go to the
polls but also that they should hand him
his job back donna
all right abigail beeman and gatineau
quebec thanks you can watch the debate
on global at 9 00 pm eastern and on our
website at globalnews.ca you can also
listen on global news radio
maxine bernier did not qualify to take
part in the official debates today his
people's party of canada said it has
removed one of its writing association
presidents from his post over
allegations he threw gravel at liberal
leader justin trudeau shane marshall was
president of the party's elgin middlesex
london riding he's accused of throwing
gravel during a liberal campaign event
on monday the canadian anti-hate network
has linked marshall to white
nationalists and anti-lockdown content
online
well kovan 19 is still with us and the
fourth wave is having a major impact
especially in the west the rate of
active cases in saskatchewan in last 14
days is now the highest in the country
and in alberta the strain on the health
care system keeps growing in calgary all
elective surgeries and many outpatient
procedures have been put on hold for the
rest of the week there are not enough
beds or staff nine more albertans have
died of covid 19 in the last 24 hours
doctors saw this coming and as heather
urex west explains frustrated patients
are asking why more wasn't done to
prevent it
laura restrepo is used to going under
the knife the calgary teen has had nine
surgeries in seven years to remove
tumors caused by a rare genetic disease
she was supposed to have surgery again
this week it was scheduled for yesterday
and they called me two days ago in the
afternoon to cancel so that was very
upsetting for everyone i literally cried
i
was frustrated and i
don't know where to turn anymore annie
claire lepage is waiting for a
hysterectomy the pain of stage four
endometriosis is so bad now it's often
causing her to miss work but her surgery
is canceled too the cancellations come
as alberta's health system grapples to
care for a surge in kovid 19 hospital
admissions i'm willing to come here
day after day after day
many in the medical community began
warning weeks ago that this day would
come alberta opened fully in early july
but it was only last week that the
government reinstated a province-wide
mass mandate the unvaccinated still
numerous enough to allow covid 19 and
the delta variant to spread
for brain cancer patient eric mulder
that now means his treatment has been
delayed the longer the weights
the long the bigger the chance that it
progresses further to a point where it's
virtually untreatable the situation in
alberta hospitals is unlikely to improve
anytime soon the province's 100 vaccine
incentive program announced last friday
has so far only led to a modest increase
in appointments and there are no signs
that the fourth wave here has reached
its peak donna
all right heather urix west thanks in
the u.s where hospitals in multiple
states are overwhelmed president joe
biden says his patience is wearing thin
he has announced tough new measures to
get more americans vaccinated it
includes a plan for a vaccine mandate or
testing at all large employers and all
government workers jackson proskow is
with me from washington jackson
donna the delta variant has upended joe
biden's plans to bring the pandemic
under control cases and deaths are back
at very high rates here in the united
states and so as part of a plan called
path out of the pandemic the president
signed an executive order thursday
making vaccination mandatory for
millions of government workers and in a
move that impacts tens of millions more
americans the department of labor will
require companies with 100 or more
employees to mandate vaccination or
regular on-the-job testing my message to
unvaccinated americans is this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us now
the more immediate threat may be around
children and kovit as school returns in
just the last week a quarter million
students in the u.s have contracted the
virus 55 000 students have been
hospitalized in the last few weeks and
in miami 13 staff and teachers in just
one school district have died within the
last month
the president is asking all schools to
set up regular testing programs there's
a double urgency here for biden because
not only is kovid straining hospitals
but biden's approval rating for his
handling of the pandemic has fallen
sharply donna
all right jackson in washington thank
you well 18 months ago this week canada
recorded its first covet 19 death a
resident in long-term care and since
then thousands of residents in ltc's
have died from covet 19 much was made of
how the virus exposed huge weaknesses
from low staff to resident ratios and
poor pay lots of political leaders
pledged to change things so what's
happened jamie morocco is looking into
that
i still have nightmares i still can hear
the people's cries inside this winnipeg
long-term care home eddie callisto
tavares says she witnessed horrors that
will never leave her my fear was that
every time i stepped outside of my dad's
room
was what's happening to all the other
residents seniors she says were locked
in their rooms ignored terrified her
only comfort caring for her father
manuel callisto in his final moments
so many others she says were left
completely alone it feels more like a
prison than a home the system failed the
residents who died the system failed the
residents and employees who got infected
so far long-term care and retirement
home residents account for 56 percent of
the country's cova deaths more than 15
000 people
and though the pandemic clearly
exacerbated the problems in canadian
care many issues have existed for
generations we have actually been able
to
see
the the conditions that seniors are are
currently living in and have been living
for the past decades experts say it's
time for the federal government to show
leadership in the form of national
standards and oversight the federal
government does have power to look after
the health of the nation
and and so it could use those powers if
it wanted to do that justin trudeau has
promised national standards before but
another year into the pandemic there's
been no action out of ottawa we're now
starting to see the death mount again
and what it tells me is that when we
haven't fundamentally fixed some of the
issues we're just going to keep seeing
repeated issues of outbreaks samir sinha
a world-renowned geriatrician has been
preparing recommendations for long-term
care standards smaller settings that
feel more like homes one person per room
a ban on shared washrooms and at least
four hours of daily care per person
scandinavian countries particularly
denmark he says are ahead of us when it
comes to compassionate safe living
spaces for seniors they started saying
let's do what we can to support people
in their own homes for as long as
possible because that's often can be
done at half the cost is what it would
cost to care for person care for
somebody in a long-term care home in
winnipeg 56 people died during the
outbreak at maple's personal care home
today new residents are being accepted
again
callisto tavares worries we haven't done
enough to avoid more unnecessary death
this is still happening there's still
people crying out for help and there's
no one there to help and why the need
for lasting solutions in these homes
remains as urgent as ever jamie morocco
global news toronto
the high cost of housing coming up the
struggle to keep up with the demand for
homes as the pandemic heats up the real
estate market
there's been a real estate boom in many
parts of canada including here in nova
scotia low interest rates and so many
people working from home has created
huge demand and there's a housing
shortage in this province as ross lord
explains that's led to some house
hunting strategies that are unorthodox
and ugly
it's a fact of life in many of canada's
biggest cities vancouver
toronto
montreal
housing demand exceeding available
supply but it's a growing reality in
halifax too leaving more people priced
out whether they're looking to buy or
rent so i started out looking at
different buildings just look them up on
google find their website and their
phone number call them see if they have
anything and
everybody called me back and said we got
nothing that's how john barrett oglevy
ended up here in a hotel room his eight
month lease
hundred dollars a month including
utilities less than what many halifax
landlords charge there's no kitchen but
ogilvy isn't complaining concession is
probably a good word um i've kind of
resigned myself to it right like i was
excited to finally get an apartment look
for a place of my own and now this is
kind of screwed it over but
what can you do to slow down runaway
rent increases nova scotia currently has
a cap in place of 2 percent a year but
the new premier
says he plans to remove the cap
it's not the solution so we really need
more housing stock in this province
that's how we'll solve the housing
crisis
the price of houses has also escalated
in part from people moving to nova
scotia during the pandemic some to find
peace of mind
others hoping to make their dollar go
further but no such luck i had a
property that i had 32 offers on i mean
that's
unheard of
for young nova scotians sky high prices
are a downer it seems that there is very
limited ways or even prospect to like
become a homeowner
some blame the housing crisis for an
increase in temporary homeless shelters
like this one that was forcibly removed
by halifax regional police last month
the problem is now spilling over into
small town nova scotia where employers
say housing shortages are part of the
reason they can't attract enough workers
we're currently looking at options to
buy housing or to build housing
many private businesses locally have
already gone that route and have
made the investment in employee housing
for their businesses the real estate
industry itself is calling for the
government to waive the provincial
transfer taxes saving home buyers
thousands of dollars but there's no sign
of immediate relief to make finding a
decent place to live more affordable
ross lord global news halifax
still ahead an example of the family
doctor so many canadians are searching
for
one of the biggest issues for voters
here in nova scotia and across the
country is health care in particular
access to a family doctor the canadian
medical association estimates about 5
million canadians don't have a primary
care physician that has a trickle-down
effect from late diagnoses to a heavy
reliance on hospital emergency
departments
we went up the road from here to meet a
family doctor who has found a way to
make things work for people in his
community perfect you could call his
approach old school you know the heart's
sounding good there michelle dr michelle
chiasson is the kind of family doctor
tens of thousands of canadians long for
you get to know your patients you get
really meaningful relationships you get
to know the grandparents the parents and
the children the whole families primary
care physicians family doctors are you
know the foundation of health care
instead of a big city practice he chose
cheda camp an acadian fishing village on
the west coast of cape breton island
nova scotia
community is everything from his role as
a hockey coach to the babies he's
delivered
to his rounds at the long-term care home
his connections here are deep we have to
cover the emergency department we cover
the hospital we do our clinics we do
nursing home we do the youth health
center we do home visits you know we're
an important resource to the community
and very happy to be that resource to
the community
he admits it can be daunting at times
sometimes uh you know you are the one
dealing with something at three o'clock
in the morning and there's no there's no
surgeon or specialist down the hall
the key is collaboration he is not alone
he's one of four family doctors here
supported by a team nurses family
practice nurses doctors our ot our
physiotherapist social worker we have a
team that gets together and really cares
for the patients so what i really would
say is to the government that they
really need to focus on putting teams in
place
not just trying to recruit
an extra doctor here they need to look
at all these communities big and small
and realize that medicine is changing
now let's have a look at these thumbs
here right the population is aging the
care they need more complex
we have tons of phone calls every
every week from people
from sydney from glace bay from port
hood who would like to come to shetty
camp
to see a doctor
you know and unfortunately you know if
they're not in their catchment area we
can't see them
it's nice to see you he's a rare breed
part of a team of family doctors
offering the kind of cradle to grave
health care canadians expect
but that is increasingly elusive
it was here in bedec over a century ago
that aviation history was made that
story coming up and this is the kitson
island lighthouse built in 1912.
we're back from vedic nova scotia in a
moment
there's only one way to get across this
great country in a day or so and that's
by airplane it's so easy i take it for
granted and so do our political leaders
who crisscross the country campaigning
but imagine more than 100 years ago when
passenger jets were still a dream seeing
the first powered flight of a plane in
canada well it happened right here in
tiny badeck nova scotia thanks in large
part to the man who also invented the
telephone
alexander graham bell whose genius
helped shape the modern world adored
nova scotia and the stately home he
built in the deck is still standing
best known for inventing the telephone
he was equally obsessed with something
else
flight it was here 112 years ago that
the first powered flight in canada and
the british empire took place it was a
cold february day for door lake frozen
solid was the runway
this was the place canada first entered
the era of flight
it was called the silver dart a delicate
looking contraption that had no brakes
was difficult to maneuver and was made
of steel tubing wires bamboo and wood
men on skates helped steady the wings
and badeck-born pilot john alexander
douglas makurdi gracefully took to the
air mccurdy got inside the aircraft
and he rolled it on the ice for about
maybe 500 feet it uh lifted off the air
got up to about 80 feet and flew for
about
two kilometers among those watching
alexander graham bell he and his wife
mabel were passionate about flight at a
time when most considered it a wild idea
people thought bell was a bit of a nut
bar anybody that was involved in
aviation in those days was considered a
bit out to lunch
even before the wright brothers had
taken off at kitty hawk bell had done
hundreds of experiments with kites and
had assembled a team called the aerial
experiment association its aim was
simple put a man in the air
we breathed an atmosphere of aviation
from morning till night bell said and
almost from night to morning
it was a fun airplane to fly ed lubitz
built a replica of the silver dart this
was a rocket ship of the day i mean this
was a
absolutely cutting cutting-edge
state-of-the-art airplane we spent a lot
of time saying well what would a 1909
mechanical engineer know
and the answer was a lot more than you
would think innovations from that plane
endure today from ailerons the hinged
edges on the wings that control the role
of a plane to the tricycle undercarriage
i'm not going to take anything away from
the historic
implications of the wright brothers but
i would say to you the silver dart is
equally as important
because of the innovation in the
engineering and the scientific
principles they applied as well quite a
legacy for a small cape breton town when
alexander graham bell loved so much he
chose it as his final resting place
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with some of the stunning vistas
from cape breton island i'll see you on
tuesday from quebec city as we cross the
country in the countdown to the federal
election thanks for watching bye
[Music]